Problem 17.
The three dimensional figure
above has 2 parallel
bases and 18 edges.
I could try to draw it, but,
well let me draw that.
So their bases are both
hexagons, essentially.
So I have one base that
looks like this.
I have time so let me
draw it properly.
So the base in front looks
something like this.
And then the top base is just
a small version, or smaller
version, that looks like that.
Whoops.
And then they draw-- these are
the front edges-- look
something like this.
Under the rear edges in a darker
color, so you know,
that they're in the back.
Rear edge.
I should have drawn that later,
because that's going to
switch back to this.
And just paint over this,
just so you know,
these are in front.
OK, good enough.
And they tell us that this
point up here is v.
I don't know if that even fit
on the video, but hopefully
you can see that
point up there.
The three dimensional figure
above has two parallel bases,
this is one base, that's
the other base.
Two parallel bases
and 18 edges.
Line segments are to be drawn
connecting vertex v with each
of the other 11 vertices.
Each of the 11 vertices
in the figure.
How many of these segments
will not lie on
an edge of the figure?
So an edge of the figure is
essentially, well let's see
what they're saying.
Line segments should be drawn
connecting vertex v with each
of the other 11 vertices.
So what are the other
11 vertices?
Let me draw them.
Let me do it in a
brighter color.
There's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
And they want to know, how many
of these segments will
not lie on an edge
of the figure.
And actually I think this is a
little ambiguous, because if
something is on the face of
the figure, on a base.
OK, well they're saying
the edges.
They're defining the
edges as the lines.
So there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18 edges.
So it can lie on a face
and still count.
So how many of these line
segments can I draw?
Well, if I want to draw a line
segment with every point on
this base that is
not on an edge.
So this one won't count, because
that is on an edge
right there.
But I can draw 1.
Oh I should use a different
color, because this is going
to get messy.
I can draw 1, 2, 3, because I'm
connected to the other 2
with an edge.
So I have three there.
And then how many can I draw a
line segment to in the other
that I'm not connected
already with an edge?
Well the way to think about it
is, this point is connected to
this only here.
So we can't use this as one
of the line segments.
But then there's 5 other points
that it can connect to,
where you're not going
through an edge.
So you're going 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So there's 5 more.
3 plus 5 is equal to 8.
And if you wanted to do that
even without drawing it you
could have said, well, there's
two types of vertices.
There's the ones that are on
the top base, and the ones
that are on the bottom base.
On the top base, which was the
hexagon, this was our point
right here.
On the top base with the hexagon
there are 5 other
vertices, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
But you're connected directly
to 2 of them.
So there's only going to be 3
that you can go where you're
not already connected to them.
And likewise, on the bottom
base, if this was the bottom
base, vertex v was
only directly
connected to this one.
It had an edge directly
to that one.
But the other 5, it didn't
have a direct edge to.
So all of those would
have been fair
game for the problem.
So 5 on the bottom it can
connect to, and 3 on the top.
And that's where we
got our 8 from.
Next problem.
Alright.
This looks like something
that I need to draw.
That's my x-axis, that's
my y-axis.
Let me label them, x, y.
And then they drew a rectangle
that I'll do
in a different color.
It looked something like this.
It looks like that.
And then how do they label it?
They said that this point, c,
is the point 1/2 comma c.
This point b is the point
minus 1/2 comma b.
My microphone is hitting
my sweatshirt.
And then, let's see, this point
here, a, is minus 1/2 a.
And then finally, this point
here, d, is 1/2 comma d.
And then they drew a graph in
between this whole thing that
intersects.
It goes from here, then it
starts to flatten out.
It's already looking kind like
an x cubed graph, if you're
familiar with what an x cubed
graph looks like.
And it goes through
that point.
Of course there's
a point here.
Note, figure not
drawn to scale.
In the figure above, abcd
is a rectangle.
Points a and c lie on the graph
of y equals px cubed.
This is y, it looks like,
y equals px cubed.
Fair enough.
Where p is a constant, if the
area of abcd is 4, what is the
value of p?
So area is base times height.
Can we figure out what
the base is?
Well sure.
We know that this is 1/2,
because the coordinates of
these two, the x coordinate
is 1/2.
We know that this is minus 1/2,
because the coordinates
of these two are, the x
coordinate's minus 1/2.
So if this length is 1/2, and
this length is 1/2, we know
this entire base is 1.
So if we know the area is 4 of
this entire rectangle, what is
this height?
This distance is going
to have to equal 4.
Because 4 times 1 is the area,
and 4 times 1 equals 4.
So this has to have height 4.
And this is symetric, right?
Well, do we know that
it's a symmetric?
It's a rectangle, points
lie on the graph.
Do you know how we know
it's symetric?
Because this is y
equals px cubed.
And anything that is px cubed
would be symmetric like this.
At 1/2, whatever pointed it is
at c, it would be at a similar
point down here.
But it would just be on
the other side and
in the third quadrant.
So it's kind of like you're
flipping it over the origin.
But anyway, so if we assume that
that's symetric, then we
know that this distance is 2,
this distance is minus 2.
If this distance is 2,
then now we know a
point on this graph.
We know that c must be equal
to 2, because that's the y
coordinate.
Now we have a point on
the graph, so we can
substitute it back in.
y equals px cubed.
So let's put 2 for our y,
because we know that that's a
point of the graph.
We know that point 1/2,
2 is on the graph.
So if we put 2 for y,
we get 2 is equal to
p times the x value.
p times 1/2 cubed.
So 2 is equal to p over 8.
1/3 cubed, oh sorry
I can't do math.
I did 1/2 over cubed.
1/3 cubed is 27.
3 squared, 9, 27.
So p, multiply both sides
by 27, is equal to 54.
And all we did here is we just
said, well, let's figure out
what this side is.
We know that this side is 1,
because we can look at the
minus 1/2 and the 1/2.
So this side has to be 4.
If this side is 4, and it's
symmetric, it goes just as
much as above the x-axis as
below, and we know that
because this is an x third,
x cubed function.
We know that this side must
be 2, or that the y
coordinate is 2.
And then we just substitute into
y is equal to px cubed to
solve for p.
I'll see you soon.